Lucia wants to test whether playing
violent video games makes people more
violent he asks his friends whether they
play violent video games and whether
they have been in a fight in the last
month he recorded the results in the
table shown below fill in the table to
show the fraction of each group of
students who have been in a fight then
decide whether there is an association
between violent video games and getting
in a fight amongst Lucio's friends so
let's see what they're doing here so
students who play video games fractions
who have been in a fight fraction who
haven't students who don't play violent
video games fraction who have been in a
fight fraction who haven't so let's
answer the first part of this students
who play violent video games so let's
look at those students so the students
who play violent video games that looks
like Ellen plays violent video games let
make sure let me just focus on the data
that we care about so Ellen so let's
look at all the all the people who play
violent video games so let's see this
column is about in video games so we
have a yes here actually have both of
these right over here and then we have
down here and then that's all of them
there's one two three four five people
who play violent video games now what
fraction of them have been in a fight
well it looks like one out of the five
have been in a fight the rest of them
have not been in a fight so we could say
1/5 let's just write that down so 1/5
have been in a fight 1/5 have been in a
fight fraction who haven't 4/5 so that's
all these other knows they play violent
video games but they haven't been in a
fight 1 2 3 4 4/5 so students who don't
play violent video games
well that's everyone else and let's see
how many data points that is that is 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 so
there's a total of 15 students and how
many of them have been in a fight so
let's see we have 1 and then let's see 1
& 2 & 3 so 3 out of the 15 have been
enough
fight so 3 out of 15 is the same thing
as 1 out of 5 those are equivalent
fractions and then the fraction who
haven't well that's just going to be
everyone else that's going to be that's
going to be 12 out of 15 or 4 out of 5 4
out of 5 so based on Lucio's data based
on Lucia's data and this wasn't a huge
sample size obviously he only found five
kids who were playing violent video
games and one of them had gotten into a
fight so we're not this isn't a super
rigorous study but at least based on his
data for trying to decide whether
there's an association between violent
games and getting into a fight amongst
Lucille's friends it doesn't seem like
there is it seems like relatively
whether or not whether or not they play
violent video games or not 1/5 of them
have been in a fight in the last month
so it really doesn't see any seem any
difference if this number was I don't
know 4/5 or 5/5 or you know all of them
then I would say hey you know even with
Lucio's fairly small sample I would say
you know maybe there is some type of a
strong association between playing
violent video games and fighting but it
here you really don't see any difference